[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everybody
it is me elise and because you asked for
it
i am making every single dish from food
wars part one
shokugeki no soma or food wars follows
the story of yuki hirosoma and his quest
to become a full-time chef and surpass
his father basically they just cook all
the damn time unfortunately
i don't have an apron like yukihira but
i do have
a headband i'm ready
let's go the first dish i'll be making
is the gacha pork roast that soma made
when he was defending his restaurant
against those urban life people
step one juggle your potatoes and when
you're done with that boil and peel them
chop up some onions and mushrooms into
tiny pieces a light of fire stare
intensely into the camera
and then saute those mushrooms and
onions once your potatoes are softened
go
ahead and mash them up a little bit and
then add in that sauteed mixture
now it's time to use your hands go ahead
and combine it all together
don't forget to salt it and then you're
going to put it on some plastic wrap and
form it into a little potato baby create
a bacon bed
in a crisscross formation and go ahead
and put that baby to sleep
don't forget to wrap it up nice and
tight cut some cooking twine and tie it
securely go ahead and add a few sprigs
of rosemary for frog logs
here are some ingredients for your glaze
and once it comes out of the oven go
ahead and pour that glaze on it and it's
beautiful
nice and spicy yeah and that's it
i mean can you just look at that all
right let's slice it
there it is
all right
it doesn't taste like a pork roast but
it does taste delicious
the next two dishes i'll be making is
somas egg souffle and arenas eggs
benedict that they both made during the
breakfast buffet challenge
two egg dishes at the same time i have
the egg
come down with me hello you need to
separate the yolks from the whites which
i obviously messed up
also crack two eggs in separate
containers for later
immersion we're gonna beat the egg
whites until just about stiff peaks and
then we're gonna give
these a mix what do you call these egg
yolks we're gonna fold the egg whites
into the egg yolk what do we need now
obviously
obviously add the salt and pepper and
then your masterpiece
is complete let's cook it butter butter
butter
pour your souffle mixture into a pan on
low heat cover it let it cook
also pour those two eggs from earlier
into a pot that's simmering
gotta tighten it as we mix with the
immersion whisk we're gonna slowly add
in the butter
it should get nice and thick salt it fry
your bacon and your english muffins
oh yeah mr souffle
and fold it right
down the hatch okay let's assemble the
gum
eggs benedict we've got our two english
muffins
bacon look at how beautifully poached
that is we gotta pour on the hollandaise
uh
omg
last but not least just a sprinkle of
parsley
our two egg dishes are complete
my forehead is sweating i have arenas ex
benedict and yukihira's
egg souffle do you want to try some
here you can't have it
it's losing some of its jiggliness
fluffy
we gotta keep on moving i'm going to
take a break for a second we're going to
go back to past
elise and she's going to show you how
she made an interesting meal
and then we'll come right back past
elise
hello it's me pastor elise and i am
making
a dish that i have no business making
apple
risotto this was a dish made by soma for
his 490th
battle against his father which of
course he loses
and for good reason because apples
i like apples but only in apple pies so
when i was making this risotto
i was so stressed because they're like
add the onions had the apples
risotto it you know and then i'm adding
butter and the salt and pepper and in
the process of making this
i was stressed but then i plated it the
bacon was looking
crispy then i layered those apple slices
on there because you know we gotta be a
little bit cute come on
and then it was time to eat it now i
really
wish i could say that i absolutely hated
this dish
because of my disdain for apples but
honestly i already tried this as i was
cooking it
it's actually quite nice it doesn't
taste
like apples it has just like this sweet
savory flavor sweet from the apple juice
and the apples and savory from the bacon
and like the butter and the cheese ooh
i didn't think it would taste good but i
actually really enjoy this and low-key
it might be the favorite thing that i've
made today and that's saying something
because i hate apples now back to
present elise
it's my final act for real okay i'm
tired
i smell like bacon my feet hurt i need
to call it a day
but i i wanted to make one more and that
is
grilled squid tentacles smothered in
peanut butter
i grilled the squid that was the easy
part i got some weird fancy peanut
butter because
and i'm suddenly questioning why
i am doing this it's supposed to be
grilled squid tentacles
why is my butter not melting oh
oh this is almond
why is it dripping out of it
[Music]
okay just go go you really thought i was
gonna eat that squid
you really thought i was gonna eat that
you really thought i was gonna eat that
simply
no all right y'all that's all i got for
you today that's
every single dish from food wars
obviously part one
there's almost 300 dishes in the entire
anime
is gonna be a while if you guys liked it
definitely
tell me the other dishes from food wars
you want me to make or from other animes
or shows
in general next time i'm gonna have an
apron yeah